America's Baby Boomers along with
surviving members of older Generations
are about to fuel the greatest wealth
transfer of all time in the US today
according to the Federal Reserve Boomers
control a stunning $75 trillion and
their Elders another $18 trillion of the
nation's $141 trillion in total
household wealth while many middle class
retirees will spend their savings the
richest 1% hold 31% of net assets
meaning that most 1centers will lead
plenty to their children grandchildren
and favorite causes out of 88 million
living Americans born before 1965 Forbes
has identified 572 us billionaires we
estimate they have a collective net
worth of 3.9 trillion to pass on and
many aren't planning to pay anything in
a estate tax former Goldman Sachs
president Gary con famously quipped only
morons pay the estate
tax the estate tax used to be a real
Revenue razor but a quarter Century of
political Regulatory and Court decisions
have limited how much revenue the tax
can bring in Congress raised the amount
that a married couple can pass on to
airs without owing estate or gift taxes
from $1.35 million in 2000 to almost $26
million this year the full $26 million
can even go into a generation skipping
or Dynasty trust meaning it can grow in
value for grandkids or later generations
without any further gift or estate tax
Ed the result of that is that only
0.004% of deaths resulted in estate
taxes in 2020 down from 2.18% in 2000
under current law the state tax
exemption will fall by about half in
2026 when the temporary Trump tax cuts
from 2017 expire but the IRS has agreed
that if that happens it won't attempt to
claw back and then tax money already
transferred during life using the larger
exemption one way the rich have long
been applauded for avoiding taxes is
through philanthropy Which is far easier
to love than a
loophole in 2010 Warren Buffett Bill
Gates and Melinda French Gates created
the giving pledge which requires signers
to devote the majority of their wealth
to charitable causes during life or at
death
since then 104 current American
billionaires worth $1.5 trillion
including 77 born before 1965 have
signed but not all giving is purely
charitable recently a new breed of
social welfare nonprofits has started
clouding the meaning of philanthropy
since these organizations can engage in
an unlimited amount of issue lobbying
and substantial direct political
activity which are things that
traditional Charities cannot do last
year Koch Industries chairman and co-ceo
Charles Coke gave $4.3 billion of
non-voting coke industry stock to
believe in people a witch based non
for-profit created under Section 501 C4
of the tax code a C4 is a broad category
of social welfare organization that
includes everything from Volunteer Fire
companies to the National Rifle
Association and the American civil
liberties Union in contrast to a
traditional 501c3 charity C4 can own an
entire company indefinitely and as long
as these activities support its
principal purpose engage in an unlimited
amount of lobbying get directly involved
in politics and benefit private
individuals there's no income tax or
estate tax deduction for giving money to
a C4 as there is to a C3 but in 2015
Congress made a crucial tweak to the law
that a Coke Lobby is promoted that
change Exempted transfers to a C4 from
the gift tax so a living billionaire can
therefore give a C4 a big gift of Highly
appreciated stock without paying either
gift or capital gains tax the C4 can
then sell the stock capital gains
taxfree or hold on to it indefinitely
reaping the dividends also capital gains
taxfree while a few billionaires have
put their entire companies into C4s K's
$4.3 billion gift to believe in people
is the largest in dollar terms to a C4
that has been publicly
disclosed one of the most popular tools
for transferring appreciating assets to
airs or nonprofits taxfree is the
granted retained annuity trust Gratz
basically frees the value of property
transferred to the trust which could
typically Ally be business interests
Securities or real estate so that the
future appreciation of that property
will pass estate tax free to the grur
beneficiaries Barry Diller the founder
and chairman of Internet and Media
conglomerate IAC particularly hates
grats but they're mainstream now so he
has used them in addition to the $400
million of stock in former IAC
subsidiary Expedia that Diller currently
holds in grats he's also transferred
more than $1 billion of other assets
through grass to different trusts for
his airs dealers can and unrepentant
about having used a tax saving technique
that he considers bad policy he told me
you live within the tax code and if it
says you can do this or that and it's in
the broad mainstream why would any
sentient person act another way Phil
Knight told me he plans to give the
majority of his wealth to charity but he
says that won't happen during his
lifetime because he's taken a slow and
deliberate approach in order to do it
right he was very outspoken about his
belief that the Charities he supports
will use his money better than the
government will so he R USS using the
tax avoidance tools Allowed by the tax
code as an important way to maximize the
amount of good he's able to do his son
Travis seems to agree with him on that
he acknowledged that some may disagree
about who's the best Steward of his
dad's Fortune but he told me I just know
that everything that he's been doing is
all in an effort to produce the greatest
most meaningful good he added I know
that when it's all said and done all
that money is going to be put back into
the world after doing all this reporting
I kind of came away wondering what the
point of having an estate taxes if it's
so easily avoidable other than I guess
creating this lucrative industry for the
lawyers and accountants who set up these
tax avoidance structures I definitely
didn't find clear answers to a lot of
the complex questions that the topic
involves like whether Society could
benefit from the dollars billionaires
spend on their personal philanthropy
being pooled and used to fund government
programs we all agree on but they're
definitely interesting questions to
[Music]
ponder